il va falloir vraiment bien faire tout
ce qui est demandé à rhodes règle
surtout une expérience digne des grands
chercheurs pour cette classe de 3e du
collège debussy les règles sont donnés
par une biologistes du cnrs audrey du
futur dans le cadre du programme élèves
tombent loeb va découvrir la réaction du
globe donc là on a juste mis de l'eau
dans le blob la fête le groupe et on va
voir son comportement nous observons un
nouvel organisme qui n'a pas forcément
pu intervenir avec toute notre vie c'est
intéressant on a c'était mieux qu'un
cours vous ont fait que par les noms
étaient donc dans l'action ça diffère de
ce qu'on fait à l'école généralement
c'est ça a été assez bien à faire ça a
permis de
pour ceux qui veulent faire des études
scientifiques ou quoi de voir ce qu'ils
vont faire plus tard un protocole strict
à suivre pour deux expériences menées
aussi dans l'espace par thomas pesquet
les résultats menées par les différentes
classes participantes sont comparés à
ceux du spationaute français inédit dans
l'année scolaire
habituellement on travaille pas dessus
maintenant on va pouvoir s'en servir
pour une année 3e c'est l'exploitation
d'un protocole respecter le protocole
utilisé le matériel ans avoir travaillé
par binôme en près d'un an suivant bien
tout le protocole sans demander trop
l'aide du professeur longue donc ça
s'intègre parfaitement dans le programme
une fois les blobs réveillés ils ont été
placés dans le laboratoire du collège et
filmé le collège debussy continue dans
son approche pluridisciplinaire il nous
donne rendez vous en décembre pour
suivre un cours de français